ils viennent du roudourou de l'autre
bout de la france une quarantaine
d'artisans et de commerçants sont
présents ici sur le marché de noël de
pontarlier des bonnes affaires pour les
clients mais aussi pour les
professionnels
[Musique]
oh
je fais uniquement de marché noël sinon
je vends par facebook ou alors les gens
m'appellent ils viennent dans mon
atelier et puis choisissent toujours
fait du sur mesure 3 qui est intéressant
c'est compact avec les genres on lie à
un échange
et quand tu financiers pour vous
franchement oui
ah oui je veux pas dire que moi ça fait
quatre ans je le fais je suis très
content de ma semaine de comptage je
reviens donc si vous traversez la france
j'imagine que ça veut dire que c'est
rentable de venir je suis le sud japon
l'année dernière c'est qu'on a une
grosse tempête de neige pendant une
semaine c'est qu'on a moins bien on a
travaillé mais moins bien que c'est que
quand on commence à gagner d'argent mais
on a envie d'y jouer
quand vous avez des produits qui sont
convenables que les gens impossible de
ce qu'ils peuvent goûter
donc non il n'y a pas de problème pour
que ça vaille le coup quand même d'avoir
un peu froid voilà quand partira
dimanche soir dans le 24 on sera autre
chose si on est content monde
alors bertrand gaschard vous êtes l'élu
en charge du commerce et de l'artisanat
ici à pontarlier
pourquoi une ville comme pontarlier qui
ait pas grande comme besançon
montbéliard pour une ville de cette
taille là investi sur un marché de noël
c'est sur un marché noël parce que c'est
l'animation du centre-ville c'est les
fêtes de fin d'année c'est un moment
familial festif
je pense qu'on doit marquer le coup
c'est les traditions les très attaché
aux traditions dans le haut doubs
ça coûte cher à la municipalité alors ça
coûte on essaye de faire que ça coûte le
moins possible pensez bien ces périodes
coûte cher ça coûte
non pas tellement cher on a des recettes
a qui sont les locations de chalets la
publicité qu'on peut faire on a essayé
de trouver des moyens de faire des
recettes supplémentaires
ça va coûter une quinzaine de milliers
d'euros enfin l'arrêt en fin de marché
de noël le solde par contre cette année
on aura bien sûr en plus puisque va nous
coûter la sécurité qui sont dues aux
événements tragiques qui vient de se
dérouler au stade de suisse faire les
marchés noël en français oui y'en a pas
en suisse mais c'est mieux pourquoi ces
violences et c'est pas cher c'est ce
qu'il dit foie gras je peux pas vous
dire qu'on écoute aussi plein coeur
non c'est bien c'est moitié moins cher
mire
alors qu'est ce qu'on voulait faire
cette affaire juste avoir d euros
c'était oui mais ce que j'en ai vu
d'autres
[Musique]
oui
frank esser un nom sur cette patinoire
fil des attractions majeures du marché
c'est pas de la vraie glace propose
avait ce choix plusieurs raisons déjà
pour des raisons de nuisances sonores
c'est vrai que tant vis-à-vis de la
vraie glace il ya une obligation de
toujours raisonné de refaire de la glace
et c'est des nuisances sonores en place
entre eux ville c'est quand même
compliqué et puis la deuxième chose
c'est au niveau de l'entretien mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on dirait de
passe soit puisque avec les problèmes
d'eau qu'on a connu
on n'a pas ce problème il n'y a pas une
goutte d'eau nécessaire à la glace
naturelle ou synthétique en tout cas
pour moi les patins vous voyez c'est pas
trop naturelle
n'hésitez pas à vous à venir en profiter
le marché noël ici à pente alliés est
ouvert jusqu'au 24 décembre prolongation
jusqu'au 30 décembre pour la patinoire
et quelques chalets alentours
profitez-en bien les fêtes à bientôt